[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport
l'émission est toujours consacrée à
l'actualité sportive dans le département
c'est parti pour le sommaire foot ball
trap a réalisé la bonne opération de
cette 18e journée de régionale 3 les
trappistes se sont imposés contre
aubergenville et prennent la tête du
championnat le résumé dans ce magazine
handball le grand prix à du conseil
départemental des yvelines était
organisé ce week-end une centaine de
jeunes est venu à verser dans le cadre
de ce tournoi
l'occasion pour les recruteurs de
trouver les futures pépites du handball
français coup de projecteur sur
l'événement gymnastique les championnats
de france approche la compétition sera
organisée du 24 au 26 mai au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
pour nous parler de ce rendez-vous nous
recevrons dans se destine cette édition
des gymnastes est l'une des
organisatrice de cet événement
l'actualité sportive de la semaine c'est
maintenant sur tb 78
[Musique]
tout de suite direction les terrains de
foot ball trap jouer gros ce week-end
dans le championnat de r3 et les
trappistes ont su répondre présent face
à aubergenville en s'imposant sur le
score de 2 buts à 0 le résumé de la
rencontre un montage signé exigea stade
gilbert gensac de trappes les joueurs
locaux sont concentrés dans le tunnel
avant d'entrer sur la pelouse les
trappistes savent qu'en cas de victoire
contre aubergenville il faudra un grand
pas vers la montée en régionale 2 une
fois l'engagement donné les trappistes
tente de prendre l'ascendant massy light
moss en arrive à marquer sur ce corner
et aux coups font ensuite le break juste
avant la mi temps par car à quoi tu as 2
à 0 c'est une première mi temps
maîtrisée dans l'ensemble pour
mènent au score 2 à 0 maintenant voilà
une deuxième période contre une équipe
qui joue le maintien il va falloir plier
le match
on met en troisième but est surtout pas
les laisser espérer au retour des
vestiaires 3 pouces pour se mettre à
l'abri mais n'arrive pas à conclure
malgré plusieurs situations dangereuses
dans cette deuxième période
score final 2 à 0 on en parle c'est de
jouer au contraire on a attaqué
malheureusement on n'a pas su
concrétiser les occasions mais bon là
aujourd'hui on va retenir la victoire
après cette victoire trappe occupe
désormais la première place du
classement à deux journées de la fin du
championnat
c'est le sprint final de match c'est pas
le moment de baisser les bras surtout
quoi donc on va mobiliser nos forces
rester concentré essayer de finir au
mieux qu'à avec deux victoires on monte
donc là on va essayer de finir
correctement
prochain match pour les trappistes le
dimanche 19 mai sur le terrain de rueil
malmaison mais en attendant les joueurs
peuvent savourer
[Applaudissements]
des images qui font toujours plaisir à
voir du football encore avec le
championnat de national troyes
versailles s'est imposé dans la douleur
face aux gobelins ce samedi soir lors de
la 23e journée les joueurs de la cité
royale ont emporté 3 à 2 sur leur
terrain de victoire la dixième de la
saison qui leur permet d'entrer dans le
top 5 de la division avec 36 points à
égalité avec le quatrième à paris-xiii
toujours en football mais cette fois ci
dans le championnat de première division
de district en match en retard carrière
grésillons a réussi à s'imposer à
domicile face à plaisir score final 2 à
1 au classement les plaisirs à pointe à
une inquiétante 10e place de son côté
carrière grésillons remontée occupe la
8e place du championnat
on continue par du rugby versailles est
toujours invaincu cette saison après
avoir terminé premier de la poule
honneur et après avoir raflé un titre de
champion ile de france la semaine
dernière les hommes de la cité royale
ont toujours faim ils ont emporté ce
week-end leur 32e de finale du
championnat de france contre lille à
villeneuve
score final 27 à 0 ils rencontreront le
club de vesoul au dimanche 19 mai en 16e
de finale
on va sortir à layrac est à présent le
padel était à l'honneur ce week end dans
les yvelines le padel club de bois
d'arcy organisé un tournoi avec les
meilleurs joueurs français
l'occasion pour le public de découvrir
ce sport venu d'amérique du sud et
popularisé en espagne à reportage
d'aurélie rance une raquette une balle
et quatre joueurs sur le terrain
voici les principaux ingrédients d'un
match de padel à mi chemin entre le
tennis et le squash ce sport ibérique se
pratique en salle pour ce tournoi p500
46 équipes se sont affrontées au paddle
club de bois d'arcy
il s'agit du seul établissement
yvelinois où l'on peut pratiquer ce
sport en là on a environ 300 à 400
joueurs réguliers par mois qui viennent
je veux pas d'allouer au badminton et
puis voilà on a on a plus de 7000
joueurs qui sont passés depuis
l'ouverture
c'est très très bien pour le club mais
aussi pour le paddle en général qui ne
cesse de prendre
voilà c'est certainement ludique et si
conviviale qui convient à tous
concernant les règles on compte les
points comme au tennis en deux sets
gagnants avec tout de même quelques
particularités au niveau du service on
va servir à la cuillère ça sera pas un
service par an à la cuillère après
rebond
ce qui est important c'est que la balle
rebondisse toujours une fois sur la
moquette du camp adverse si on envoie la
balle au dessus du filet et qu'elles
touchent directement le mur ses fautes
sport très populaire dans les pays
hispaniques le padel fait aujourd'hui de
plus en plus d'adeptes en france c'est
vachement plus ludique et on peut
vachement plus s'amuser sans forcément
avoir un niveau de langue devant moi
j'ai pas un gros niveau de tennis ni de
padel d'ailleurs mais je m'éclate à la
clac en enfer je verrai au moins quatre
fois par semaine actuellement 5300
personnes font partie du circuit
français
le nombre de pratiquants dépasse quant à
lui les 50000 après le padel on va
parler de son cousin le tennis et plus
particulièrement de tennis handisport
johan guillou qui s'entraînent dans les
yvelines a brillé fin avril à marseille
il a réussi à emporter les championnats
de france par équipes de tennis fauteuil
nationale 2 pour nous parler de ce
rendez-vous nous recevons sur ce plateau
i want you
bonsoir bonsoir alors quel est votre
sentiment après cette victoire c'est une
très belle victoire puisque ça faisait
trois quatre ans j'avais pas du ppu du
coup jouer les championnats par équipes
aux championnats de france du coup de
tennis fauteuil
c'était sur les terrains du coût de la
spt de la fourragère à marseille
donc c'est plutôt on va dire une belle
région pour voir
faire cette partie de tennis on a gagné
on n'était pas forcément favoris on
était 4e de la poule en nationale 2 et
avec un super travail d'équipé avec les
coaches le soutien du club voisin
bretonneux on a réussi vols aller en
finale et remporter du coup ce titre de
champion de france c'était une
compétition relevée relevé oui quand
même en nationale 2 puisqu'il y avait
quand même des bons joueurs en qui
valent en 2e série première série donc
il y avait quand même un certain niveau
donc il a c'était des matchs avec des
partis quand même assez accroché donc on
a gagné on a gagné
certains matches ont des double décisif
et ce qui est intéressant également
c'est que c'était un format un peu coupe
davis 1 totalement c'était deux simples
et un double donc le joueur numéro 1 le
joueur numéro deux et si l'un des deux
paires d ont joué un double décisif
c'est l'un de vos plus beaux souvenirs
en tennis fauteuil
oui c'est l'un des plus beaux souvenirs
après j'ai ça reste quand même et titre
en individuel mais c'est vrai que
partager un titre en équipe c'est
toujours ça fait toujours plaisir
c'est un travail d'équipé on partage les
mêmes valeurs cette même passion c'est
le fruit aussi plusieurs heures
d'entraînement avec du coup le soutien
du club du comité de tennis des yvelines
des joueurs aussi mes coéquipiers donc
là aussi nous en cours mais puis
stéphane gervaise qui s'entraîne
également la section handisport donc je
suis vraiment très content pour eux
qu'ils aient pu décrocher ses torts et
j'espère que ça va leur permettre de
continuer sur cet élan et on a été un
petit peu particulier vous l'avais dit
c'était à marseille vous avez battu le
club local
en finale tout à fait vrai qu'on peut un
public en feu de marseillais on va dire
ouais ouais on a fait la finale le
dimanche matin il y avait vraiment
beaucoup beaucoup de support pour
l'équipe du coût de la fourragère qui
est le club qui nous a accueillis
malheureusement pour eux un petit peu un
goût d'amertume parce qu'ils auraient
voulu remporter l'or on les a battus
voilà c'est la loi du sport et
voilà on est on est content de l'avoir
fait quoi qu'est ce que ça va vous
apporter une victoire comme celle là une
victoire comme celle-là c'est en termes
déjà voilà de pouvoir communiquer un
petit peu plus sur le para tennis le
tennis fauteuil en termes de médias
aussi de pouvoir voilà pouvoir justement
communiquer sur ses résultats
souvent parle beaucoup de tennis valide
également ainsi donc mettre en avant si
le club la section handisport et donnait
aussi envie du coup grâce à ces un peu
plus cette médiatisation donner envie à
des jeunes de pouvoir pratiquer ce sport
et de se dire bah moi aussi un jour je
peux décrocher l'or vous avez vous allez
gagner des points également oui avec des
coûts des points pour le classement du
coût individuel donc on a des points du
cou qui pourront nous permettre de nous
qualifier pour les championnats de
france mas moi en tout cas après les
autres joueurs je ne sais pas et vous
vous en êtes où justement au niveau de
votre classement au niveau du classement
national je suis toujours partie des
meilleurs joueurs français en 1re série
et donc je suis dans le top 10 donc au
niveau classement national depuis deux
ans effectivement je joue un petit peu
moins puisque j'ai une activité
professionnelle à temps plein je suis en
train de me remettre là du coup sur le
plan international justement ligne de
mire avec pour les jeux de paris 2024
mais il va falloir encore que je
tructures mon projet que je m'entraînais
un peu plus rajouter un peu plus de
préparation physique et surtout du temps
et pouvoir trouver des partenaires pour
ça il faut vous dégager du temps si je
comprends bien pour réussir tout à fait
ben oui puisque maintenant aujourd'hui
un athlète de haut niveau handisport
dire on va dire c'est les mêmes sessions
d'entraînement qu'un valide donc là avec
des semaines à 40 heures avec un travail
à temps plein il va falloir quand même
que j'arrive à me dégager du temps un
aménagement de temps
qui va être nécessaire du coup pour un
projet de haut niveau de ce type et ça
représente combien de temps environ
d'entraînement par semaine
aujourd'hui je suis à 1h30 2h de tennis
plus une petite heure de préparation
physique donc globalement choix trois
heures de sport par semaine en plus de
mon activité là si vraiment je veux
vraiment me remettre sur du haut niveau
en ce qui est vraiment totalement
possible et de par mon handicap
également il faudrait au moins au moins
une dizaine d'heures de sport par
semaine
voilà je pense que c'est minimum la
moyenne d'un athlète handisport
aujourd'hui qui se projette pour des
jeux paralympiques
c'est ce qui fait la différence vraiment
une peau au niveau oui bah il y as à ce
qui fait la différence hier s'ils font
ses entraînements à 10h15 heure par
semaine
ah oui oui minimum minimum puisque tous
les meilleurs faut au moins 10 heures où
entre 10 et 20 heures il en vise à riva
en vivre dans certains pays notamment
les pays du nord on va dire qu'ils ont
quand même mis en place des structures
qui permettent à des jeunes de pouvoir
s'entraîner et également de faire du
goût du sport études en france en train
de venir avec du coup le tennis fauteuil
et à raccrocher à l'activité il ya
encore un chantier qui est en cours mais
j'espère en tout cas qu'on est sur la
bonne voie pour pouvoir justement faire
sortir les futurs champions de demain on
parler de vos objectifs léger ou 2024
on l'a compris est ce qu'il y aura
d'autres échéances
avant ces jo de 2024 parce que c'est
quand même assez loin ouais c'est sûr
que c'est loin après il ya toujours les
championnats de france individuels qui
se déroule tous les ans du coup donc là
c'est toujours une occasion pour moi de
me confronter aux meilleurs joueurs
français qu'on connaît d'ailleurs il ya
les coupes du monde effectivement mais
on reste toujours sur des sélections de
trois quatre joueurs minimum puisque
maintenant les objectifs de la fierté
c'est de rapporter des médailles et des
titres et puis du coup en tennis
fauteuil du coup après il ya les
tournois et visible est évidemment
gagner des tournois soit des petits
tournois des tournois de catégorie futur
avec
l'opportunité pourquoi pas de gagner des
tournois un peu plus majeur peu plus
important sur des catégories tf2 et tf1
voir des grands chelems mais voilà pour
ça quand je leur dis faut s'entraîner il
faut effectivement s'impliquer
s'impliquer quoi et si vous ne rêvez pas
vous qualifier pour ces jo de 2024 est
ce qu'il ya une possibilité pour que
vous alliez dans l'organisation de ces
jo paralympiques
ouais on parle beaucoup de
l'organisation des jeux de 2024 par une
numéro 4 effectivement il ya pas mal
d'emplois qui s'ouvre après je pense que
moi concrètement je pense que je
partirai plutôt vers le coaching dans le
monde associatif d'aller sait détecter
des joueurs ici ayant ayant un handicap
puisque dans l'encadrement continuer
dans le dans le monde associatif
pourquoi pas entraîner me taper la balle
avec des jeunes d'autres personnes
issues d'une maladie ou d'un handicap
qui souhaitent jouer au tennis fauteuil
merci à vous dépasser sur ce plateau
vivendi ou encore bravo pour votre
performance à marseille si ces gens vous
souhaite de conquérir de nouveaux
trophées dans les prochains jours sera
évidemment sur tv 78 on va maintenant
rangé les raquettes de tennis si on va
sortir les battes de base-ball ça va
mieux pour les cougars de montigny le
bretonneux dans le championnat de
première division lésigny montain se
sont imposés deux fois ce week-end
contre les cavigal de nice les scores 19
à 5 dans la première partie et 6 à 3
dans le second match avec sept victoires
montigny le bretonneux consolide sa
deuxième place de la poule b chien du
handball à présent dans le championnat
de nationale 2 féminin l'ice montigny le
bretonneux n'y arrive pas lésiné
montagne se sont inclinés sur leur
terrain contre aurons une équipe
pourtant à leur portée
au classement cette huitième défaite
fait redescendre l'équipe à la huitième
place du classement à quatre points de
la septième place la fin de saison
s'annonce compliquée à pour l'équipe
handball masculin rien ne va plus
également pour plaisir les pzero en
concéder un troisième match nul cette
saison ils ont été tenus en échec 30
partout par le leader l'entente asnières
colombes résultat qui n'arrange pas les
joueurs de victor garrigues et le point
désormais une inquiétante 10e place sur
12 synonyme de relégation
il reste trois matches à disputer on
continue à parler de handball le grand
prix du département des yvelines était
organisé ce week-end à versailles lui
départements de la ligue ile-de-france
sont envoyé leurs meilleurs joueurs et
joueuses de 12 à 13 ans pour participer
à ce tournoi l'occasion pour ces jeunes
de se faire à détecter un montage de
xavier jallais
dans les tribunes rien ne lui échappe
alexandre taillefer est venu pour
observer les joueuses du grand prix du
conseil départemental des yvelines et
sportives venues des quatre coins de
l'île de france ont scruté avec
attention son lent plusieurs critères
pour regarder les matches nous ont
affiché fédéral qui nous permet de de
dévaluer sur est statistiquement les
joueurs avec des repères physiologiques
des repères morphologique des repères
techniques des repères sur la
combativité et puis à partir de là on
on définit les postes ont mené des
joueurs vers le haut niveau c'est
l'objectif de ce tournoi créé il ya 32
ans
on est vraiment au premier niveau de la
détection en france sur l'âge le jeune
joueur la chercheuse donc ça rentre tout
à fait dans
l'objectif du comité c'est de dire de
voilà de détecter les jeunes et de
former les jeunes une source de
motivation pour les joueuses de 12 à 13
ans venus de huit départements
d'ile-de-france à se donner beaucoup
plus que ça en étant au club comme suit
2000 s'agissait de carole population
d'aller vite fin faut donner le plus
qu'on peut qu'augmenter renouveau aller
au plus haut niveau plus cuisse et
ensuite
aussi m
depuis une dizaine d'années seulement 1
à 2 joueurs par édition arrive à percer
et à intégrer les équipes de france ce
jaune un mot de course à pied sidy
diallo ligne montrent un os plus de 200
marathon ultramarathon sur sept
continents vient de sortir un livre son
nom au running man l'ouvragé explique
sur une centaine de pages les capacités
naturelles des humains courir pieds nus
et sans peine des dizaine de marathons
par an le sportif comparé notamment
notre corps à celui des homo sapiens qui
devait chasser pour survivre le livre
sur la théorie de sidy diallo est
disponible dans toutes les librairies
hameau de cyclisme direction le
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines faire du vélo
en toute sécurité grâce à des qcm des
parcours sur circuit avec le code de la
route l'opération savoir rouler a permis
à des enfants de 6 à 11 ans d'apprendre
à circuler en autonomie sur leur deux
roues un programme lancé par le
gouvernement auquel la fédération
française de cyclisme a été associé
plusieurs jeunes ont pu passer une étape
de leur attestation mardi réaction leur
montrer que utiliser le vélo ça
nécessite des compétences des
compétences pour savoir évoluer dans le
cadre de la route qui est partagée avec
d'autres utilisateurs les voitures mais
aussi les trottinettes les piétons
et puis c'est savoir manier son vélo
savoir évoluer en sécurité ça veut dire
savoir être à l'aise avec son son
support vélo on passe maintenant à notre
page agenda direction nouvelle fois le
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines
[Musique]
le vélodrome national de saint quentin
en yvelines va accueillir du 24 au 26
mai les championnats de france de
gymnastique par équipes
une première pour la structure pour nous
parler de ce rendez-vous nous recevons
sur ce plateau l'une des responsables de
l'organisation morgan ou la revend
swarte également vice-président de la
gemme elancourt maurepas nous recevons
également deux championnes du club julie
à mougins et mathilde de terre bonsoir
alors comment vous sentez vous à
quelques semaines d'organiser cette
grande première au vélodrome de 50 entre
ces traits c'est ça approche non mais
les choses se préparent sont en bonne
voie
voilà on s'organise on est à trois
semaines maintenant de l'événement donc
les derniers petits détails à régler
les imprévus de dernière minute parce
qu'il y en a toujours et voilà ça ça
s'organise un petit peu de stress aussi
du côté des participantes
gilles pour l'instant pas encore ça va
pas tarder à arriver mais là c'est
encore calme même si la ration on va à
l'entraînement centre est né pour être
est le changer une petite routine qui
s'installe comme d'habitude alors morgan
est-ce que tout est prêt au niveau de
l'organisation whisky encore beaucoup de
travail à accomplir
tout n'est pas encore prêt on va pas se
mentir mais
mais non la plupart le gros est fait on
peut dire ça comme ça
maintenant voilà ils restent les
derniers petits détails à régler des
petites choses à qu'on ajoute
qu'on ajoute parce que on vient
finalement ça peut être une bonne idée
voilà on sait qu'on est très attendu ces
championnats de france parce que c'est
une première et d'une part au vélodrome
et en plus ça fait vingt ans que ça n'a
pas eu lieu en ile de france
en plus là on est dans une structure
olympique est le vélodrome nationale
donc voilà on sait qu'on est assez
attendu au tournant donc forcément un
peu de stress sur cet événement
justement grosse attente de la part des
organisateurs ou des autres comités de
la part des comités qui nous soutiennent
donc le comité départemental des
yvelines le comité régional
d'ile-de-france de la part de la
fédération française de gymnastique et
puis voilà on n'a pas envie non plus de
décevoir les partenaires institutionnels
et privés qui nous soutiennent on a une
grosse aide de la part de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines d'un point de
vue logistique entre autres sur ces
championnats de france donc voilà on a
envie de décevoir personne et d'être à
la hauteur de l'événement et outright
plus qu'en même temps sur cet événement
sur ces championnats depuis vraiment
dessus depuis septembre après on a
candidaté sur cette organisation en fin
de saison de l'année dernière donc voilà
à peu près juin septembre sur ces
championnats de france
est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner les
gros chiffres y aura combien de
compétiteurs par exemple alors on attend
à peu près pas loin de mille cinq cents
compétiteurs gymnase donc masculin et
film on attend donc oui ça fait à peu
près entre 250 et 300 équipes et on
espère atteindre 5000 personnes en
termes de spectateurs
on va également accueillir à peu près
600 scolaires des écoles primaires
principalement de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et quelques
collégiens sur la journée du vendredi
des compétiteurs venus de toute la
france
vraiment toute la france y compris les
territoires d'outre-mer
voilà les meilleurs gymnastes français
seront présents ils ont réussi à se
qualifier en équipe donc voilà on les
attend avec impatience je lis comment ça
se prépare
en championnat de france ben comme
n'importe quel autre compétition
on répète nos mouvements on essaie de
peaufiner les derniers détails pour être
vraiment prête aussi bien techniquement
que psychologiquement le moment de la
compétition
et puis on espère réussir à reproduire
ce qu'on travaille plusieurs fois par
semaine parce que juste avant ces
championnats par équipes des
championnats individuels ainsi si j'ai
bien vu qui se rend ce week-end et
qu'est ce que ça change justement
championnat individuel d'un championnat
par équipes
bah ça dépend des gymnastes en
individuel on a que la responsabilité de
sa propre compétition
mais si on réussit ça n'atteint que nous
si on rate ça n'atteint que nous aussi
en équipe
alors on fait passer quatre gymnastes à
chaque agrès par équipes il ya que les
trois meilleures notes qui compte
potentiellement c'est plusieurs
gymnastes pour une erreur ça va
pénaliser toute l'équipe
donc ça peut amener un peu plus de
pression mathilde comment préparer un
événement quand on lit la tête que comme
vous est ce que c'est
plusieurs mois avant est ce que ces
quelques jours avant ben commence à
préparer dès septembre lorsqu'on reprend
l'entraînement après les vacances d'été
on a des raisons d entraînement régulier
et puis l approche des compétitions
commencent à intensifier les
entraînements pour être prête le jour j
qu'est ce que c'est finalement une
compétition comme celle-là c'est c'est
le graal pour pour vous bah oui quand
même hein c'est une réussite c'est des
championnats de france
tout le monde n'y a pas accès et puis
bah c'est une joie quand même de les
faire de représenter son club et de se
dire on a fait les championnats de
france
c'est l'aboutissement d'une saison je
pense aussi
pour les journées de faire un très joli
le gran également toujours sur tour
national bah oui alors quels sont vos
objectifs
justement julie sûr c'est sur ces
championnats de france et ben de faire
la compétition la plus réussie possible
de pouvoir rentrer tous les éléments
qu'on travaille à l'entraînement pour
aller faire le meilleur résultat
possible ne pas avoir de regret une
médaille
on va fasse intervenir des organes
est ce qu'elles ont un potentiel pour
pour avoir des médailles oui elles ont
le potentiel pour avoir une médaille
après comme le dit julie le plus
important et le plus difficile je pense
pour les gyms et de pouvoir reproduire
en compétition ce qu elle s'affaire à
l'entraînement et ce qu'elles pratiquent
plusieurs fois par semaine mais quand
les voyages entraînement du jour à 7
peuvent emporter une médaille bien sûr
quand on les voit à l'entraînement elles
ont raison tout le potentiel et nous on
est à fond derrière elle et on croit on
est le seul à 100% du club a déjà
remporté les médailles
oui le club a déjà remporté des
médailles par équipes l'année dernière
on en a pas vu je crois si on a eu une
équipe à poitiers voilà chaque année on
espère ramener le plus de médailles
possibles après c'est le jeu de la
compet le stress le jour j la façon de
le gérer
et voilà la moindre erreur peut être
fatale en gymnastique donc justement
mathilde est ce qu'il faudra jouer avec
l'appui du public du goût sera domicile
par quasiment à domicile
sûr que le public va apporter une grande
aide on aura nos amis notre famille et
même tous les membres du crest dans le
temps les gradins donc ça va nous aider
à bas nous donner à fond et réaliser nos
objectifs c'est particulier pour une
compétition comme celle-là d'avoir
justement sa famille ses amis autour de
soi parce que c'est pas forcément le cas
partout en france
j'imagine bah ça va pas toujours du
soutien de se dire on va remplir nos
parents va rendre fiers de dominer donc
sa faim ça motive
julie et même chose c'est du soutien en
plus c'est pas du stress justement
d'être devant sa famille et ses amis
peut-être supplémentaires avoir envie de
trop bien trop bien faire face à encore
ça dépend de la perception de chacune
mais pour moi non c'est plutôt la
motivation des soutiens morgan vous êtes
d'accord
donc oui je pense que c'est ça peut
booster en effet d'avoir toute sa
famille et ses amis derrière soi après
en effet je pense que notamment les plus
jeunes
à mon avis elle se met peut-être une
pression supplémentaire du fait d'avoir
toutes leurs connaissances autour d'elle
à les encourager
est ce qu'il reste des places ça sera
mené à une question il a commencé par en
effet
on va sur gmail ont pour l'heure pas
point com voilà sur le site du club sur
nos réseaux sociaux facebook instagram
et autres il reste des places en effet
ça commence à partir de 9 euros la place
et on a des tarifs préférentiels et pour
les clubs de gymnastique tous très des
rations confondues et pour les habitants
de saint quentin en yvelines
il ya des package peut-être pour les
trois jours exactement on a des places
pour le départ week-end des packs trois
jours des packs pour les tarifs de
groupe quand on est en club de
gymnastique donc voilà on trouve toutes
les solutions pour que vous puissiez
venir nous voir
merci à vous tous trois d'être passé on
se bat on vous souhaite bon courage pour
l'organisation et on sera évidemment
présent pour l'événement pour rappel les
championnats de france de gymnastique
seront organisées du 24 au 26 mai au
vélodrome nationale 2 à saint quentin en
yvelines ont continué cet agenda par une
course la quatrième édition du run and
bike de maurepas est programmée ce
samedi 11 mai les départs en duo soit en
données du stade du bois à partir de 15h
pour les courses jeunes et adolescents
le 16 km débutera quant à lui à 17
heures et devrait regrouper plusieurs
centaines de sportifs
si vous voulez vous inscrire reste
encore quelques places en basket très
gros match pour verser dans le
championnat de prénationale les joueurs
de la cité royale vont affronter en
quart de finale 2 à l'équipe de basket
paris 14 à l'extérieur une équipe à leur
portée
la rencontre est prévue ce samedi à 20
heures dans la salle de didot à paris le
retour sera lui a prévu le 18 mai
prochain à 20h à domicile il y aura
également du foot us ce week-end avec la
10e et dernière journée de la saison
régulière de deuxième division les
templiers d'elancourt recevront ce
samedi soir à 19h les diables rouges de
villepinte les templiers déjà assuré de
terminer premier de la poule b auront à
coeur de terminer sur une note positive
afin de préparer les playoffs
la rencontre aura lieu au complexe
sportif europe et on termine par du
baseball les cougars de montigny le
bretonneux participeront à partir de
jeudi jusqu'à ce dimanche au challenge
de france à montpellier
un rendez vous qui réunit les meilleures
équipes du championnat qui permet une
équipe de décrocher une place en coupe
d'europe lésigny montant joueront leur
premier match ce jeudi à 11h face au puc
de paris
si la fin de cette émission merci
d'avoir suivi très belle soirée sur tv
sur 118
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]